Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Séverine !
Je crois que là, c’est un peu l’heure
de ton TEDx, s’il te plaît.
Tu veux bien poser
ce que tu as dans la main
et le donner à Julien
qui est à côté dans la régie.
Séverine, c’est l’heure !
Excusez-moi, j’étais absorbée
dans mon jeu vidéo.
Julien, tu termines... Voilà.
Bonjour à tous !
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui m’intéresse particulièrement
en tant que chercheuse,
c’est de comprendre
les effets du numérique.
Et là, c’est une vaste question.
Ces trente dernières années,
les technologies du numérique
se sont largement imposées
dans notre société.
Elles ont profondément modifié nos vies,
nos échanges sociaux,
nos relations intimes,
nos activités de loisirs,
notre travail,
nos activités d’apprentissage.
Ces technologies font maintenant
partie de notre quotidien,
mais leur diffusion rapide suscite
de nombreuses inquiétudes.
Dans les médias, on parle souvent
des effets néfastes des écrans
sur la santé physique
et psychique des individus.
Et dans la ligne de mire : les jeux vidéo.
En soi, ces questions sont légitimes
puisque de nombreuses interrogations
demeurent sur les effets des écrans.
Entre 200 et 400 articles scientifiques
sont publiés chaque année dans le monde.
Et finalement, c'est beaucoup.
Certains s’intéressent aux liens entre
le jeu vidéo et, au choix, l’agressivité,
les troubles de l’attention
ou encore les performances scolaires.
Pourtant, dans ces articles, on ne trouve
que des associations très faibles.
Aujourd’hui, on manque encore de recul
sur les effets des jeux vidéo
et on est encore loin d’arriver
à un consensus scientifique.
La question n’est pas : «Les jeux vidéo
sont-ils bons ou mauvais ?»
Non, ça, ce serait beaucoup trop simple.
Les questions sont plutôt :
«Le jeu vidéo entraîne-t-il
de l’agressivité
ou des troubles de l’attention ? »
«Les systèmes manipulent-ils
les joueurs ?»
«Y a-t-il une population
plus à risque ?»
Pour répondre à ces questions,
l’Organisation mondiale de la santé,
en 2019, intègre le trouble du jeu vidéo
dans le classement international
des maladies
et le définit comme, je cite :
«un trouble comportemental
qui se caractérise par un usage excessif
et compulsif des jeux vidéo
qui interfèrent avec la vie quotidienne. »
Ce trouble nécessite une prise en charge
psychologique par un professionnel.
Selon les chiffres de l’OMS,
entre 2 à 3 % des joueurs présenteraient
des usages problématiques.
2 à 3 % des joueurs dans le monde.
Mais alors,
comment expliquer qu’il y ait environ
2,7 milliards de joueurs dans le monde,
c’est-à-dire à peu près un tiers
de la population mondiale ?
Si ces joueurs ne présentent pas
d’usage problématique,
comment expliquer qu’ils aiment
jouer aux jeux vidéo ?
Et moi-même, qui joue un peu,
ai-je un problème avec les jeux vidéo ?
Bon, je vais vous raconter un truc.
À 13 ans, on m’a offert
une Game Boy et j’ai adoré.
D’ailleurs, j’adore toujours des briques
à empiler, des courses de voitures,
des bonhommes roses au pays des rêves.
Alors oui, effectivement,
on m’a attendue à table pour manger.
J’étais à fond dans mon jeu
et finalement,
j’ai déchargé toutes les piles.
Mais c'était tellement bien.
Et pourquoi d’ailleurs ?
Parce que le jeu vidéo permet de répondre
à certains besoins psychologiques humains,
comme par exemple le besoin de relations
sociales, le besoin d’accomplissement
et également le besoin d’autonomie.
Le besoin de relations sociales
car le jeu permet aux joueurs
de se rencontrer en ligne.
On peut rencontrer l’amour dans
les guildes de World of Warcraft.
Mais également dans la vraie vie,
où les gamers se rencontrent
lors d’événements.
Le besoin d’accomplissement
parce que quand on finit un niveau,
on bat le super-vilain
et on sauve le pays des rêves.
C'est un super accomplissement.
Et puis, il y a également
le besoin d’autonomie,
car le jeu offre beaucoup de liberté.
Il permet d'explorer un nouveau monde,
un nouvel univers à l'infini.
On est libre de nos actions
et on recherche finalement
l’amusement et le fun.
Quand un jeu permet de répondre
à ces différents besoins,
on tient un bon jeu.
On va dire qu’on est au niveau un
du plaisir de jouer.
On passe un bon moment.
Mais il existe un niveau deux
du plaisir de jouer.
Celui qui nous pousse à revenir
faire une partie.
Celui qui nous fait oublier le temps
et celui qui nous fait
nous oublier nous-même.
Ce n’est pas de l’addiction,
mais un état de conscience modifié.
La recherche de l'expérience ultime.
Ce qu’on appelle le flow.
Souvenez-vous, tout à l’heure,
on m’appelait là-bas
et je ne répondais pas.
Eh bien, c’est parce que
j’étais en état de flow.
Le flow est un concept que l’on doit à
un chercheur, Csikszentmihalyi.
C'est un état de concentration intense,
d'absorption, d'engagement dans la tâche.
Dans cet état de conscience altérée,
les individus agissent
de manière automatique.
C’est une expérience
qui génère du bien-être
et c’est une récompense en elle-même qui
va pousser les joueurs à revenir jouer.
Csikszentmihalyi a découvert cet état
en observant des artistes travailler
fiévreusement sur leurs œuvres.
Leur attention était tellement focalisée
qu’ils oubliaient de boire, de dormir,
de manger.
Il oubliait même leur propre corps,
tant l’engagement dans la tâche
était profond.
Le flow, c’est un état de plaisir
que l’on retrouve dans
plein d’activités quotidiennes,
par exemple la musique,
le dessin, le sport.
Parfois même dans le travail ;
si, si, je vous assure, ça arrive.
Donc, finalement, le flow,
c’est un état souhaitable
accompagné de conséquences positives.
Beaucoup de gens expérimentent cet état
de flow en jouant aux jeux vidéo.
Si, comme moi, vous avez décidé
de relancer une petite partie
et que cinq minutes se sont
transformées en une heure,
si vous n’écoutez pas,
si vous n’entendez pas,
les gens qui vous appellent
pour venir manger,
c’est peut-être que vous aussi
vous avez déjà connu cet état de flow.
Alors attention, cet état n’arrive pas
n’importe comment.
Il arrive dans des conditions
très particulières.
Tout d’abord, il faut un équilibre
entre les compétences du joueur
et les challenges du jeu.
Donc ces challenges doivent augmenter
au fur et à mesure
de la progression du joueur.
Il faut aussi une bonne histoire
avec des récompenses à la clé.
Et enfin, il faut un objectif premier -
admettons chasser un dragon.
Et puis également des objectifs
plus secondaires,
par exemple, se construire une maison
ou encore élever des cochons.
Quand ces conditions sont réunies,
vous pouvez atteindre cet état de flow.
Mais qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
Vous êtes dans un état
de conscience modifiée,
c’est-à-dire que vous avez
un sentiment fort de contrôle.
Vous êtes hyper concentré,
vous vous oubliez vous-même.
Plus rien ne vous distrait,
vous perdez la notion du temps
et enfin, vous ressentez du bien-être.
Y a-t-il un problème à éprouver du flow,
c’est-à-dire à prendre du plaisir
dans les jeux vidéo ?
D’après vous ?
En fait, le flow, c’est un état
qui procure du bien-être.
C'est ce que dit la littérature.
Donc, si comme moi, vous aimez jouer
avec un petit bonhomme rose
et vous battre contre un arbre maléfique,
si vous jouez de manière raisonnable,
on va dire à peu près deux heures par jour
et que vous éprouvez du plaisir à ça,
finalement, c’est une bonne chose.
De la même manière qu’on peut éprouver
du plaisir en jouant de la batterie,
c’est une bonne chose.
De la même manière qu’on peut éprouver
du plaisir à faire du skate,
et finalement, c’est une bonne chose.
Il n’y a donc pas de mal à éprouver
du plaisir quand on joue aux jeux vidéo.
Si, évidemment, cela ne remplace pas
les vraies interactions,
celles avec votre entourage,
si cela ne nuit pas à votre sommeil.
Il faut concevoir le jeu comme
quelque chose qui doit s’insérer
de manière raisonnable à côté
de tout un tas d’autres activités.
Quand on comprend le flow,
on cerne mieux la relation
des joueurs aux jeux vidéo.
On comprend, par exemple,
pourquoi ils ne vous répondent pas
et aussi pourquoi il ne faut pas
couper brutalement le joueur
au milieu de sa partie.
Allez, imaginez, vous êtes en train
de regarder votre série préférée.
8 ans que vous êtes dessus.
Vous allez enfin savoir
qui va monter sur le trône de fer.
L'épisode final dure 78 minutes.
Sauf que, moi, j’ai autorisé uniquement
60 minutes de visionnage.
Donc, au bout de 60 minutes,
je vais venir vous voir et vous dire :
« Le temps imparti pour regarder
cette série est terminé»,
et bam ! je coupe.
Il est fort possible que cela crée
chez vous une forme de frustration,
le fait que je coupe cet état de plaisir.
Eh bien,
finalement, c’est exactement
ce que font certains parents
quand ils demandent
à leurs enfants ou à leurs ados
de couper brutalement leur jeu.
Généralement, ça se traduit en frustration
et parfois même en colère.
Donc,
laisser le joueur finir son niveau,
sa partie, sa quête,
cinq, dix minutes de plus,
finalement, ce n’est pas grand-chose
à côté d’une grosse frustration.
Pour ma part, j’ai pu présenter mes héros
vidéoludiques à mes enfants
et eux m’ont présenté les leurs.
C'est un moment de partage essentiel
quand on est parent.
Donc n’hésitez pas à jouer avec
vos enfants, à accompagner vos ados,
discuter du contenu, discuter de la
partie et aussi des relations sociales
parce qu’il y en a
qui se nouent dans le jeu.
Et surtout, surtout, prenez du plaisir
à jouer tous ensemble.
Laissez-vous bercer par le flow,
car c’est peut-être une partie
du secret du bonheur.
(Applaudissements)